ja man kann sie leider nur schlecht
lesen aber per Twitter mit einer
einfachen Frage jetzt kann man mich
überhaupt nicht sehen warte mal so
geht's hat mich Diego auf die Idee
gebracht nämlich er fragte wen
interviewst du denn als nächstes den
Checker und das heißt natürlich es muss
auch ein fragevideo geben das heißt ich
muss euch natürlich die Möglichkeit
geben dem Checker dann auch Fragen zu
stellen also deine Frage an den Checker
die ist jetzt wieder gewünscht
Videoantwort also in den Kommentar ins
Kommentarfeld klicken daneben gibt's
dann einen Button oder ich muss mal
gucken ob ich hier irgendwo einen Button
noch reinlege eine Anmerkung kann man
auch drauf klicken am besten Video
Anworten Kommentare jetzt bei K1 und
flir hab es wirklich nicht geschafft
einen Kommentar zu beantworten also am
besten Videos und zwar mit kreativen
fragen die haben die besten Chance und
für alle die jetzt noch nicht gecheckt
haben wer der Checker ist das ist ich
glaube der fünfte bei der aktuellen DSDS
also der letzten DSDS Staffel Thomas
Karaoglan heißt er und hat dort ziemlich
für veror gesorgt und jetzt einen sehr
lustigen schmissigen lockeren Sommerhit
aufgelegt
ja das ist der Checker also jetzt haut
rein